AND THE UPSIDE DOWN HEARING GOES
UPSIDE DOWN.
>> FIRST, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
LEGAL TEAM TURNS THE TABLES
LAYING OUT THEIR ARGUMENTS
AGAINST IMPEACHMENT AND FORGET
THEIR BREVITY.
IN A FEW CONCRETE WAYS, THEY
DISMANTLED KEY PIECES OF THE
DEMOCRATS RATHER INCOHERENT
CONSTITUTIONAL ARGUMENT.
I WILL BREAK DOWN A FEW PIECES
TONIGHT FOR YOU.
THE MOST IMPORTANT ONES.
THE CORE CLAIM OF DEMOCRATS
IMPEACHMENT ARTICLE IS THAT
TRUMP SPEECH INCITED THE JANUARY
HIS SPEECH ON JANUARY SIX, HERE
IS STRONG COUNSEL MICHAEL
VANDERVEEN.
>> THE SENATE SHOULD BE
EXTREMELY CAREFUL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT THE PRESIDENT THIS
CASE HAS SET.
CONSIDER THE LANGUAGE THAT THE
HOUSE IMPEACHMENT ARTICLE
ALLEGES TO CONSTITUTE TO INCITE.
IF YOU DON’T FIGHT LIKE HELL,
YOU NOT GOING TO HAVE A COUNTRY
ANYMORE.
THIS IS ORDINARY POLITICAL
RHETORIC THAT IS VIRTUALLY
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM THE
LANGUAGE THAT HAS BEEN USED BY
PEOPLE ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM.
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
>> AND HE HAD THE EXAMPLE.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO FIGHT.
>> WE FIGHT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO FIGHT LIKE HR
HRLL
HRLL.
>> IT’S LANGUAGE THAT THEY’VE
USED, THAT REPUBLICANS HAVE USED
, BIG DEAL.
IT SHOWS NOTHING.
NUMBER TWO, THE ATTORNEY
RESPONDED WITH THIS.
RATHER INCONVENIENT FACT.
>> DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
COMPLAINED THAT AN ELECTION WAS
STOLEN BECAUSE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THAT IS IN NO WAY INCITEMENT TO
AN INSURRECTION.
SOMEHOW WHEN DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES DECRY AN ELECTION AS
STOLEN OR ILLEGITIMATE, IT IS
NEVER A BIG LIE.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING IT FOR YEARS.
>> OF COURSE.
WE DOCUMENTED IT.
WE COVERED IT NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT.
TRUMP WAS NEVER A LEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT.
NUMBER THREE, LAST NIGHT WE
SHOWED YOU HOW HEAD IMPEACHMENT
MANAGER TRIED TO BLOCK THE 2016
ELECTION RESULTS.
TODAY THE TRUMP TEAM EXPOSED THE
CO-CONSPIRATORS.
>> I OBJECT TO THE VOTES FROM
THE STATE OF WISCONSIN WHICH
SHOULD NOT BE VERY.
>> I OBJECT TO THE CERTIFICATE
FROM THE STATE OF GEORGIA PARITY
I OBJECT TO THE CERTIFICATE FROM
THE STATE OF NORTH CAROLINA.
>> ARE THEY ALL GUILTY TO?
THEY DON’T LIKE DEMOCRACY.
KNOW THEY HAD A PROBLEM WITH THE
CERTIFICATION SO THEY MADE THEIR
STATEMENT AND THEY SAID THEIR
PIECE.
BY THE DEMOCRATS OWN STANDARDS.
ALL OF THOSE SOUNDBITES, ALL OF
THOSE COMMENTS, IN SOME WAY
CONSTITUTE ALTOGETHER SOMETHING
APPROACHING SEDITION.
TRADERS?
THAT’S WHAT THEY WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE THAT’S THE BOGUS
THRESHOLD FOR INCITEMENT THEY
OFFERED AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP
OF.
WHEN USE THE SAME LANGUAGE THEY
OPENLY QUESTION THE LEGITIMACY
OF A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THE AD THE WHOLE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION ONTO IT FOR IT IT’S
TOTALLY INNOCUOUS.
AND IN FACT, IT’S
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
SPEECH.
FINALLY, THE ATTORNEY VANDERVEEN
EXISTING FLEET EXPOSE THE
DEMOCRATS CONSTITUTIONAL
OVERREACH.
>> THE HOUSE MANAGER’S POSITION
AS STATED IN THEIR TRIAL BRIEF
WAS AND I QUOTE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT DOES NOT APPLY AT ALL
TO IN IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
THE TEXT OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT
EXPRESSLY RESISTS CONGRESSMEN
REGULATING SPEECH.
THE POSITION ADVANCED BY THE
HOUSE MANAGERS IS ESSENTIALLY AN
UNLIMITED IMPEACHMENT STANDARD
WITHOUT CONSTITUTIONAL
GUARDRAILS, UNMOORED TO ANY
SPECIFIC LEGAL TEST, UNDER OTHER
THAN THE UNBRIDLED DISCRETION OF
CONGRESS.
>> BUT IT CERTAINLY THE INTENT